you have a lot of Twitter followers
including celebrities you yeah
celebrities love you oh well some do
yeah I can think of one that doesn't
right now celebrities some of them like
me some of them don't and I have a
particular fascination with some
different celebrities like I love Lisa
Rinna Lisa Rinna she's married to Harry
ham there she is
I have a fascination with her uh-huh
right and she's one of the real
housewives now and I she started
following me and I was so excited and
then I look in two weeks later she
unfollowed me really yeah what the hell
else is Lisa Rinna doing with her time
and follow me I love her on Twitter okay
so you're you're bitter that she
unfollowed you I'm a little bit again
because I like following her tweak so
I'd like to be followed back she tweets
all kinds of amazed by the way no one
will love it more than we're talking
about her than Lisa Rinna
by the way I'll get back to work yes oh
yeah so she'll probably tweet this I
hope she follows me she tweets great
things like when that Malaysian the
plane went down yeah like two months
later out of nowhere she tweeted I think
something weird happened with that plane
on the case she's on it Lisa Rinna is on
that yeah
you